hi I'm Chris and I'm an interaction
designer with the Android project today
I'm going to talk about my favorite
feature the window shade the window
shade gives you access to your
notifications unlike most platforms the
Android platform allows you to not only
see your notifications in the upper
left-hand portion of the screen but
actually act on them using the window
shade so for example I've received an
SMS message I can just pull down the
window shade and automatically see not
only the SMS message but all of the
items that have come in on my device I
can see that I've downloaded an
application received an instant message
an email as well as that SMS and I can
see a calendar event is present as well
the difference here is that these
notifications are actionable on the
Android platform so for example I can
see that that instant message I probably
should reply to that since that's
someone I'm meeting was shortly simply
tap that message and start communicating
via google talk with that person